last night I was invited to perform at
the local Berlin band called sato opera
a lot of fans showed up
I'm here at the lead singer guitarist
frontman for Sato opera your name sir my
name is Colonel Colonel Colonel it is
very good to see you
what are you trying to express with the
band saw two opera we trust in open
sexuality there which helps people to
feel both of their sights you want me to
show that I am both man and woman am I
gonna need to take my penis and push it
back underneath no no I didn't mean to
hide your man your male side but I don't
criticize this what if so something if
someone else if someone else wishes to
talk then we do what you want kids this
is a public service announcement from
Berlin from the colonel and Konan if you
wish to tuk-tuk
your burdens you know no no I you never
did now I didn't I also don't criticize
but I don't really like if you don't
like mines that's cool too
if you're a mind that likes to tuck your
genitals back to become a woman that is
fine with us do anything you want to do
as long as you're not hurting someone
else do that yeah by the way you've met
another lover and your new lover has
some different preferences right can you
imagine if somebody offers you anal sex
for example but me you know
better-trained kind of trade me during
the show whatever they penetrate to you
off till you play the guitar
oh that's fine okay to knows I could be
kind of training other people you know
the person who can really it's a
compliment penetrate others the less you
say now okay you should probably go
change and get ready for the show
yes all right
[Applause]
introduced to you my younger brother
Connor
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
all of the fans that came all the way to
[Applause]
you
you